if someone is the focus of a museum
exhibition they're often a great
eminence of a kind but not sixty
seven-year-old British designer Paul
Smith his creations are brimming with
color prints and stripes he puts a
little bit of humor into every one of
his products
Paul Smith is a British design legend
and he's far from retirement
I think I I just was blessed with the
love of life and a calm nature and and
I'm just very interested in people and
this now and somebody in 10 minutes and
swimming in the morning and walking down
the street you know normal things
everybody gets so swept up now with what
they think they should be doing and what
they think they should be like I think
so many people live life like business
plan today Portsmouth is a design empire
with 14 product lines and some 250
million euros and annual sales each of
his shops be it in Los Angeles Tokyo
London or in any of the other locations
is a one-of-a-kind
they will reflect aspects of a
designer's broad range of interests it
all began with men's fashion
he had all types of people coming to him
but you know it could it be architects
city Barrow boys you know whole range of
different types of people that were all
interested in in the clothes that he was
creating because they offer something a
little bit special he was really the
first designer to make men's were
interesting and full of character and
make it individual the on Paul Smith
originally dreamt of becoming a
professional cyclist but a tragic
accident put an abrupt end to that and
to his schooling he found himself at the
crossroads
so I crashed into fashion I mean I
literally did yes I had a bad accident
three months in hospital came out and by
chance was introduced to people from the
world of creativity because I happened
to go to a pub in my hometown that was
where all the young students went and so
I mean you could say it was just from
heaven or just by chance or I'm not sure
but anyways turned out well in 1970 Paul
Smith opened a boutique for men's
fashion in a nine square metre shot in
his hometown Nottingham he hadn't yet
begun designing his only help was an
Afghan hound named Homer my wife and I
had two Afghan hounds you know they're
very well they look we look exactly the
same actually we we had big noses and
long hair and one
the bulbs used to work in the shop with
me but whether the shop was very small
so we were very close to each other and
he was the manager his name was Homer
Homer The Iliad and everybody used to
talk to him first and I was his
assistant
in 1976 Paul Smith presented his first
collection in Paris in a small hotel
room only one of the buyers he invited
turned up during his four-day show but
Paul Smith remained undaunted and
pressed on a down-to-earth work ethic is
part of Paul Smith's character and of
the Paul Smith brand even now almost
every sketch passes through his or his
wife Pauline's hands both designers
they've been together for some 45 years
she's my total inspiration we met we
fell in love she came to live with me
and you know just by being together she
taught me about things you know cutting
patterns about the importance of
beautiful quality kept my feet on the
ground the hello my name is Paul Smith
exhibition at the Design Museum in
London there's a look at 40 years of
Smith's work he says that isn't meant so
much as a retrospective as an
inspiration for young creative talent I
wanted to really show people that from
this modest start that you can progress
and that you can do well so it's very
much about showing the down-to-earth
nests of me and the company and also the
creative process
Paul Smith will be the design museum's
main attraction till the end of March
then who knows he might be a reporter
for euro max I'm from TV and I'd like to
say very nice
here in the post with vexation thank you